hey one I'm at the chart will welcome to
Abby's kitchen so today we're going to
be talking a little bit about a question
that I get asked quite often and that is
why don't we ever get to see a baby II I
mean I reference him quite often I talk
about my mom struggles and things that
I've been experiencing in the past
almost years since I gave birth but I
haven't actually given them guys a
chance to see him in action so I want to
talk a little bit about that a third I
want to make sure that I'm clear that
this is not meant to kind of shame other
moms about the decisions that they make
when it comes to sharing photos of their
babies or kids online second I think
that you know there's a lot of benefits
to sharing for those four kids online I
know that a lot of us have family that
live abroad or afar and you don't
actually get to see their kids every you
know every week or every month watch
them grow up and sharing those photos
online but they can she could be part of
their life there's definitely a lot of
benefits there not to mention I want
people to know that like not sharing
every single milestone of my son online
is really really hard for me I left my
own devices I am a total sharon's and a
Sheeran is basically a parent who wants
to share you know all those amazing
moments of their child's life with the
less the world I am that mom I would
totally totally kind of want to share
every photo up and in the bath and the
highchair rolling around just like
looking like a mess I want to do that
but there's a lot of reasons why I've
kind of made the decision not to and I
want to talk a little bit about its nose
today
number one is the concern over food
safety I'm a parent and like all parents
I think my role I'm number one role as a
mom is to make sure that my son is safe
and taken care of and there's nothing
that scares me more than thinking of a
scenario where that wouldn't be the case
so I not suggesting that my son would be
like an automatic target and having this
photo online just automatically means
all these weird curve in the corners the
internet are gonna come after him that
seems a little kind of conspiracy
theorist
right there however I have no idea what
the future holds when it comes to
technology and when it comes to you know
between geo-targeting and facial
recognition I just want to make sure
that I'm not setting my son up for a
scenario where his safety could be
compromised number two I don't feel like
I really have the right to curate his
digital footprint for him so I am
ultimately like a millennial and I feel
very privileged that I grew up in a
world where I got to adulthood and I had
the ability to curate my online presence
who I was or who I was perceived to be
online and I I mean I think it's gonna
be a rough go for this new generation of
kids who are growing up in an era who
have that whole digital cooker that
whole life that whole brand already
curated and already set out and aligned
for them before they even reach you know
puberty so I would love to give him the
opportunity as much as I can to curate
that life himself that I don't really
have his consent to share images or
videos of him so obviously I think my
son is a genius but he's still baby so
he really does not have the capacity to
consent to be sharing any kind of videos
or images of him I need the decision to
have a YouTube channel and share content
on it every week with you guys my son
however it did not
did he take so many photos the camera on
my phone is completely
full however until he's old enough to
consent to me sharing all of these
images online I just gonna have to keep
them to myself how will these our bottom
line here is just the fact that my
husband asked me not to put images
online so back when I was pregnant this
was something that my husband and I
really fought over I thought I was gonna
feel so unsatisfied not being able to
share my like my one true love and joy
and the thing I'm most proud of on
online with all of you guys but he was
adamant that that was something that was
no personal and saying that we should
really keep between our family and our
friends and the people who actually know
us and at the time I didn't really
understand but now that I'm a mom I can
see his perspective and more importantly
I just had to respect that this was his
little kind of one true wish when it
comes to parenting there's gonna be
things that you guys disagree on and
there's gonna have to be a lot of
give-and-take and when it comes to
taking photos online this was something
that was really really important to my
husband and it was something that I just
had to compromise on let me talk about
that compromise for a second
so one of the things that we agreed that
we would do is crazy being private
little Facebook photo album where I've
added my close friends and family so
that they can see all those milestones
that I'm so proud of so I can share
photos and videos of my baby growing up
and I don't have to feel like my family
who don't get this and very often have
no clue what's going on so for us it was
really about kind of putting up some of
those privacy settings that made us feel
a lot more confident and comfortable
sharing some those images online the
other thing that I kind of been doing is
you location seeing photos of kind of
non distinguishable elements of my son
online so whether that's like hands or
feet or legs for the back of his head
things that kind of give you guys the
heads up that yeah he still actually
exists you know I want to make sure that
I'm being genuine when it comes to my
social media and the fact the matter is
that my son is working 95 percent of my
life and if I am kind of hiding him from
you guys I would feel like I'm not being
true to who I am
and right now Who I am is ultimately a
mom and he's a huge huge part of my day
but I'm just trying to kind of protect
his identity by not showing his face or
using his full name so guys I hope that
that's gonna cleared up a lot of your
questions around why you don't get to
see photos of mr. baby II all the time
but I would love to hear from you guys I
would love to know you know do you guys
share photos of your babies online if
you do or don't I would love to know
what you've done to kind of create some
of those healthy boundaries around
safety precautions or what's happening
do you feel a little bit more
comfortable about sharing photos
definitely leave me a comment below if
you loved this video please give me the
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and I
will definitely see you next time on a
bee pigeon bye
you